DOUBLE-DOUBLE.
CHEESE.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY"
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
A FOX NEWS ALERT.
GET THIS.
JAMES COMEY, I HOPE YOU ARE
SITTING DOWN FOR THIS.
BIG BREAKING NEWS, ONLY MOMENTS
AGO, FEDERAL PROSECUTORS ARE
REPORTEDLY INVESTIGATING
HIGH-LEVEL LEAKS, CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL FROM THE FBI AND THE
SUPER PATRIOT HIMSELF, ACCORDING
TO REPORTS IS LIKELY THE TARGET
OF A CRIMINAL PROBE.
REMEMBER, ONLY A FEW MONTHS AGO
IN AN UNRELATED CASE, THE DOJ
RESPECTED --
HE LACKED CANDOR SURROUNDING HIS
COMMUNICATION WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY WILL HAVE DETAILS,
ANALYSIS, AND MORE ON THIS MAJOR
STORY COMING UP FIRST, TONIGHT,
MORE MANUFACTURED HYSTERIA FROMT
MORE MANUFACTURED HYSTERIA FROME
D.C. SWAMP.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
SIGNIFICANT, NOTHING MEANINGFUL
ABOUT THIS CHARADE, THIS
MISCARRIAGE OF JUSTICE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS,
CON ARTISTS, AND LIARS, THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN DOING IT
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS, THEY
ARE NOW DRAGGING THIS COUNTRY
THROUGH THE MUD.
IT'S ALL OUT OF PSYCHOSIS AND
INSANITY.
I WANT TO BEGIN WITH THIS
MONOLOGUE.
I WANT TO ASK EVERYONE A SIMPLE
QUESTION.
ANSWER IN YOUR MIND'S EYE, THE
I REALLY WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT
IT.
SINCE DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED
IN 2016, THANK YOU, WHAT HAVE
DEMOCRATS, WHAT HAVE THE MEDIA,
WHAT HAVE YOU EVER DONE TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF AMERICANS?
NOW, HAVE THEY DONE ANYTHING TO
CREATE JOBS FOR OUR SAFETY,
SECURITY, PEACE?
ON TODAY'S COVER OF
"THE NEW YORK POST," PERFECT
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT I AM
TALKING ABOUT.
ON THE ONE SIDE, YOU HAVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, SIGNING WHAT
MANY THOUGHT COULD NEVER BE
DONE.
A REALLY GREAT HISTORIC TRADE
DEAL WITH CHINA.
$220 BILLION IN THE NEXT TWO
YEARS ALONE.
THIS YEAR AND NEXT YEAR.
THAT WILL IMPACT THE ENERGY
SECTOR, THE SERVICE SECTOR,
MANUFACTURING SECTOR, OUR
FARMERS BENEFIT GREATLY.
$220 BILLION.
THAT HELPS THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
IT HELPS AMERICAN WORKERS.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
PICTURE, THERE'S NANCY PELOSI,
SMILING, SIGNING OFF ON TWO
BOGUS ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT,
AND TAKING PICTURES WITH, YES,
NANCY'S BLATANT POLITICAL STUNT
WILL IMPROVE THE LIVES OF ZERO
AMERICANS.
IT WILL ADD ZERO JOBS TO THE
ECONOMY.
IT DOES NOTHING TO MAKE US MORE
SAFE OR SECURE.
WE ALL KNOW THE OUTCOME.
IT'S GOING TO DIE IN THE SENATE.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO THAT THEY
SAID IT MUST BE BIPARTISAN.
NO REPUBLICAN SUPPORTED IT.
THEN, SHE RAN THROUGH ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT WITH THE SUPPORTS
OF ONLY DEMOCRATS.
SHE ALSO SAID THE IMPEACHMENT
WAS SO DIRE AND SO URGENT, WE'VE
GOT TO PASS IT IN RECORD TIME.
SHE THEN REFUSED TO SEND THE
ARTICLE TO THE SENATE FOR OVER A
MONTH.
A WEEKLONG STALL THAT ALMOST NO
ONE CAN EXPLAIN.
THEY PASSED IT SO QUICKLY BEFORE
CHRISTMAS SO THEY COULD GO ON
VACATION FOR THREE WEEKS.
DON'T FORGET, BY THE WAY,
NANCY PELOSI, SPEAKER IN NAME
ONLY, CONSTANTLY REMINDING "WE
THE PEOPLE" IMPEACHMENT WAS HER
SOLEMN DUTY.
SHE WAS SO SOMBER.
OF COURSE, THAT, ALSO A LIE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS MATTER
AND WE TAKE IT TO HEART.
AND A
REALLY SOLEMN WAY.
SO SAD.
SO TRAGIC FOR OUR COUNTRY.
DECEMBER 18TH, A GREAT DAY FOR
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES, A SAD ONE FOR
AMERICA THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
RECKLESS ACTIVITIES RESUSCITATED
US, ARE HAVING TO INTRODUCE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
THIS IS NOTHING THAT ANYBODY
TAKES ANY SATISFACTION IN.
IT'S SAD FOR OUR COUNTRY.
THERE IS NO JOY IN THIS.
IT'S SAD.
WE MUST BE SOMBER.
WE MUST BE PRAYERFUL.
>> Sean: SAD, SOMBER,
PRAYERFUL.
DO YOU WANT A PEN?
I'VE GOT DOZENS OF THEM.
HE SMILED FOR THE CAMERA.
WE DID IT.
SO PELOSI WAS SO SOMBER AND
PRAYERFUL, SHE GLEEFULLY HANDED
THE PEN TO HER SMILING
COLLEAGUES SO THEY COULD ALL
TAKE PICTURES TOGETHER AFTER
SIGNING THE ARTICLES, ALL
SMILES.
A POLITICAL STUNT BORN OUT OF
RAGE FROM BEGINNING TO END.
NOW, THE DEMOCRATIC CHARADE
CONTINUES IN THE U.S. SENATE.
TONIGHT, THEY WANT TO INTRODUCE
CHARGES AND MATERIAL AND
WITNESSES THAT WERE NOT PART OF
THE CASE.
A MEMBER, THE SOLE POWER OF THE
CONSTITUTION TO IMPEACH IS IN
THE HOUSE.
THEY PASSED IT ALREADY.
A FEW WEAK REPUBLICAN SENATORS
TRIED TO HELP THEIR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES AND ALLOWED THEM TO
CALL NEW WITNESSES TO DO THE
JOB, THE CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY OF
THE HOUSE AND ENTER ALL THIS NEW
EVIDENCE.
GUESS WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN?
THIS ACTUALLY IS A GREAT THING.
I WANT TO HEAR FROM ZERO
EXPERIENCE, HUNTER BIDEN WHO HAS
PAID MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, NO
EXPERIENCE.
WHILE MY.
WHAT A DEAL.
WHAT COMPANY WOULD EVER GIVE YOU
MILLIONS WHEN YOU KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT THE BUSINESS?
AND THEN, OF COURSE, WE'VE GOT
QUID PRO QUO JOE.
LET'S BRING HIM INTO TESTIFY.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE BILLION
BILLIONS.
THE FAKE HEARSAY WHISTLE-BLOWER
SHOULD BE CALLED TO TESTIFY.
BUT PERHAPS, MY FAVORITE WILL BE
CALLING THE COMPROMISED CORRUPT
CONGENITAL LIAR, ADAM SCHIFF.
LET'S PUT HIM UNDER OATH.
SENATOR TEN CRUISE AND RON PAUL
SENATOR PAUL IS PREDICTING NO
REPUBLICAN WILL CONVICT THE
PRESIDENT.
I TEND TO AGREE WITH HIM EXCEPT
MITT ROMNEY.
MITT ROMNEY HATES DONALD TRUMP.
EVERY SECOND OF EVERY DAY.